if you're a gardener dreaming of lush
banana crops listen up the secret might
just be beneath your feet so you've got
your banana suckers all set up ready to
transform into Bountiful bunches but
wait before you celebrate there's a
hidden enemy you need to tackle infected
soil that's right even the best suckers
can't fight back against the lurking
dangers of nematodes and fungi in the
soil these pesky Intruders can severely
affect plant growth leading to
disappointing yields solution fumigation
it might sound drastic but ensuring your
land is free from soil born diseases is
crucial for healthy banana plants don't
just plant and hope for the best take
action to protect your green investment
remember healthy soil equals healthy
plants so before you plant your next
batch of suckers make sure your land is
as ready as they are this might just be
the game Cher your garden needs
subscribe and drop a comment